joey bart got called up today i know
fans have been anxiously awaiting his
debut he's going to be hitting sixth in
the lineup he's going to be of course
catching for kevin gausman fletcher's
gonna lead things off got him
and that's how this game gets started on
a strikeout to david fletcher here's
tommy listello one out nobody on tommy
hitting 289.
and that is ripped out toward right
center field hit well yastrimsky and
dubois not going to get there one hops
defense over the wall
it's a one out double for tommy lestella
his eighth of the year man scoring
position for trout with one out
and he strikes him out 96
right over the heart of the plate two
down so guzman wins that battle it's the
second strikeout here now we'll see what
anthony wendell can do now it's shot up
the middle of base hit flores couldn't
come up with it costello's being waved
around here comes devon's throw to the
plate it is cut off and the angels have
a one-nothing lead
tonight for the los angeles angels will
be the left-hander jose suarez suarez
22 years of age he's a rookie
and this is what he did last year two
and six with a 7-1-1 era
lined on the left field line and hit
well
and it's off the bottom of the chevron
sign and slater's gonna trot into second
base with a double and it came on an o2
pitch and he has been so good in two
strike counts
so now here is wilmer flores a homer and
four rbis last night
hit a high drive into left center field
trout on the move trout on the move
out of here he's done it again
his sixth of the year
all right
he can hit he can hit and he can hit in
two strike counts and it was a 95 mile
an hour fastball down and in and he just
was not impressed with it
and we're gonna see joey bart cutouts
are giving him a standing ovation i know
they are in beaufort
he hit him
with a breaking ball
i don't think that's how he envisioned
his first fight
so two on with one out 1-1
there's a chopper toward belt he backs
up a little bit his only place to first
gaussman is there two down maybe a break
here now with fletch coming up that
could have been a double play ball
line drive and it's flores coming out of
nowhere
to make the catch to end the inning
mikey
coming into the game in the league
leaders in the national league in
most of the
major offensive categories
high drive into right center field on
the move is adele still on the move and
it's a one hopper up against the wall it
triples alley both runs are going to
score and yostrinsky's got a double he
hit that thing about 412 feet who did
matt andres the new pitcher now will be
the sixth time that he has come into a
game so two men on for the giants and
here is evan longoria
and a shot up the middle that's a base
hit
here comes jastrenski
flores is gonna go to third trout throws
the ball to second it's five to one
so here's joey bart he'll hit with the
bases loaded one-two pitch
and bart chases a pitch in the dirt so
he'll be disappointed with that at bat
now he goes into his stretch there go
the runners the pitch
inside and he has walked in a run he's
faced five hitters and he's walked three
of them
it is six to one giants tehran looking
into ben boone and the one-two pitch to
wilmer flores
and a base hit to left field
going to wave in slater here's the throw
home it's on the mark
not in time
[Applause]
as flores comes through with two more
rbis
two
crawford goes the other way hits it well
it is out of here
his second of the year
and it's nine to one
it's locked in
i mean we've known this guy for a long
time but when he locks it in he'll use
left field against righty's lefties and
he can do with power
ground ball to the right side
play goes to first base when he posts
scores
it's 9-2 and the angels once again have
runners at the corners only one out and
anthony rendon will be the next batter
fletcher third round at first radel hit
switzerland into center field on an rbi
single three hit game
and it's nine to three san francisco
[Applause]
second plate appearance he struck out
and bamboo shoots went out to right
field yastrimsky's going to watch this
one
get out of here
big fly for anthony bembo
went with an off speed pitch and it's
nine to four joey bart hit by a pitch
struck out in the second then popped out
in the fourth
[Applause]
down the left field line his first major
league hit and it was a loud one
felt is going to roll into third
into second goes joey bart
and he's got an average folks
they heard that all the way to beaufort
view for georgia
they just jumped out of bed
and they had to because this was scary
there's a loud noise a little hanging
breaking ball and joy bart says yeah
take care of that in a ballpark where
there's no people that sounded like a
shot going off
the 1-0 pitch
dickerson hits one the other way towards
the gap
but moving over is good when he's going
to make the catch
his throw is somewhere belt sports